[Musique]
laquelle me fait ressembler davantage à un
homme de Harvard Je suis ravi d'annoncer que
vous ne ressemblez en rien à un homme de Harvard qui est venu
à la faculté de droit de Harvard.
Je suis Phaedra Ginsburg et pourquoi êtes-vous
ici, mademoiselle Ginsburg, occupant une place
qui  aurait pu aller voir un homme, vous êtes la
personne la plus intelligente ici, alors dites simplement que
vous connaissez mr.  Fitzpatrick la semaine dernière, on
m'a dit que les femmes étaient trop émotives pour être
avocates. Votre enfant a démissionné. Un intervieweur
m'a dit qu'ils avaient embauché une femme l'année dernière et
qu'est-ce qu'ils voudraient
de nous deux,
vous êtes en colère.
huit perdre une forme différente
sur la base du sexe ou des lois qui disent que les
femmes ne peuvent pas faire d'heures supplémentaires pour obtenir une
carte de crédit votre mari n'est pas beaucoup de femmes
dont nous ne sommes pas autorisés à travailler à l'esprit
pourquoi voudriez-vous ce qui n'est pas le
point  nous devrions être autorisés
Je vais convaincre les tribunaux que ces
lois sont inconstitutionnelles nous allons
lire les affaires de la Cour de l'impôt lisez ceci dans la
loi suppose qu'un soignant doit être une
femme c'est une discrimination fondée sur le sexe contre
un homme donc le juge avait tort  m.  morritz la
loi est mauvaise, ils pensent que l'égalité des sexes
est un droit civil, vous devez voir l'
opportunité que cette affaire représente des hommes et des
femmes tous les deux, vous perdrez
Routh et quand vous le ferez, vous
ferez reculer la femme de 10 ans, vous n'arrivez
pas à  dis-moi quand arrêter, nous devrions nous
tourner vers sa génération, ils descendent dans
la rue pour exiger des changements, vous
feriez bien de vous rappeler que c'est un privilège,
ce n'est pas un privilège, c'est une cage et
ces lois sont l'obstacle à
toutes
vos actions.  prêt pour cela vous avez été prêt
pour cela toute votre vie nous devons tous
prendre ces lois une par une cela vous
renversez tout ce fichu système de
discrimination
le mot femme n'apparaît pas une seule fois
dans la Constitution américaine ni le mot
liberté votre  vous honorer
[Musique]